Which is it? Go ahead. Yeah, um
Well a couple call ago somebody said something about their day program and
You said it was in our book work, but I can't find it in my book work. So it's not in your book work
It's in your program folder. So
Let's see. I don't know who's asking this question
It's hearing
Oh, so it should be in your program. I could look at your program, but I'm pretty sure that you have a day program in there
So it usually I might have titled it shorter program
Um, I usually title it shorter day program, but sometimes
I'm thinking of something else and I just title it shorter program or or I just title it day program in the folder of your overnight
Sets
So
folder of your overnight sets in the right in your right folder
It'll have Sunday, Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, Friday, Saturday, and then it usually has I put one, two, three, whatever
Day programs in there as well. Oh, okay. Okay. Thank you. Okay. Thank you, but I will I will make a comment about that because
You know, so there's some people that you know their cancer is pretty stable and then they choose during the day
Let's say they come home from work and they are sitting in want to use the rife
They choose during the day to run other comorbidities like
Like the person who just mentioned they're having kidney stone issues. So during the day
He's running kidney stone programs and he might even choose to forgo his cancer programs to run kidney stones
At night because they can be awfully painful to get this to pass
so
But if the person is I I
Reckon bad if the person's cancer is fairly active that they're running
Those shorter cancer because the day programs that I put in your folder are cancer programs
so they're not
Some people have asked can you put such and such else in my program with it
But it'll be listed differently
So if it's a shorter day program. It is a cancer program
So I'm sharing what that was yeah, so that's a that's a just a shorter day
Program for your cancer
Um, and some people ask do I have to do that? I don't have time to do that. No, no, that's just if you have time
Run that too because again the more
Frequency's you could hit your cancer with the better chance. You're gonna have debts at those cancer cells. So
The biggest mistake that
People you make
Running the right not my patients
But I'm talking to other people who go buy a right machine somewhere and say it didn't work
It's because they're they're not doing it long enough plus they might be using the wrong machine
It's not even powerful enough to to get at it and they're using the wrong frequencies. So nothing's gonna work
But that's a day had the right machine and the right frequencies and if they're not getting any response at all
Doesn't mean everybody's gonna get a response
But if they're not getting any results for the most commonly, they're not using it long enough
so um
Now that's why I write them overnight programs you're getting eight hours in
But I have some people that are really really sick. They're basically doing this 24-7
Um, and then uh, if you're doing well, you're doing better
You're maybe ready different programs during the day
Okay, okay. Thank you. You bet